how long has Adam been in this water how
is he not already dead from drowning
this ladies and gentlemen is a key well
no it's a key and don't much later in
the movie when you've already forgotten
whatever it was
why did Adam get placed in water while
Lawrence is sitting here dry as a bone
nobody would be cracking wise in this
situation what does he matthew broderick
human organs have always been against
eBay's terms of service agreement I know
this tape was protected from the water
by the plastic baggie but how did jigsaw
know the tape wouldn't be smashed
between his body in the bottom of the
tub or on the tile when he fell to the
ground what would happen if adam and
lawrence never figured on how to get the
tape player i guess they just eventually
died of starvation
but how long would jigsaw of waited to
get up from the floor say well this is
awkward
he played out much better in my head
when I planned it how did you know they
wouldn't throw the tape in the tub on
accident or somewhere else out of reach
what if lawrence throws like a girl
then what Adam is a little too helpful
to the guy who's been challenged to kill
him did he not really care where the
tape started back up when he push play
or is this a character rewinds tape and
stops it at the perfect moment they were
looking for in one try cliche if you're
Adam and you've just heard the message
about lawrence needing to kill you why
would you do this danny glover isn't too
old for this in this scene door was on a
timer was unlocked until 3:00 o'clock
wait month three o'clock right now
though is it a newspaper started calling
it the jigsaw killer and this kid has
never heard of him like ever technically
speaking he's not really a murderer
he never killed anyone um no yeah he's a
murderer by law in like every state and
every civilized country and probably
even Idaho yes my wife has the car today
right the surgeon with this office and
this home only has one car this pin
light has no discernible markings and
Lawrence would have to have a criminal
record for them to match fingerprints so
how did the detectives figure out that
this was his pin light I see the only
guy in the area that uses a pen light
how did Lawrence even know it was his
cops do not let recently exonerated
suspects eavesdrop on official witness
testimony jeez a flashback within a
flashback from early 24 minutes in why
did this chick get a video from jigsaw
and everyone else got audio tapes you
know what the scene needs it needs a
rapidly edited series of jump cuts shot
with an artificially sped up camera
rotating around the room to make you
understand how completely messed up the
situation is how did she not hear him
moaning or see him moving his head in
time and how she remember him moaning
and turning his head so that it's in her
flashback in story oh wait are they
saying she did hear him moan and didn't
even flinch didn't even glance at him or
hesitate or pause for even a second the
evil puppet killer said it was a dead
body even if you would still stab him
knowing that he was alive doesn't the
information itself come as a surprise
worthy of a small pause ah I see he's
just trying to help he's seen V for
Vendetta one too many times and he
thinks torturing people actually sets
them free it's only 11:25 here but then
in the same scene after just a few
minutes of dialogue and throwing rocks
at the mirror the time has jumped to
1205 on the close-up it's a piece of
wood left in the frame of the mirror
that's sticking out exactly in line with
the camera in this shot but then when we
switch to the camera's view which has
some incredible wide-angle views by the
way there's no piece of wood to be seen
even though it would definitely need to
be there if the camera is able to see
dr. Gordon every possible angle except
the part about how easily either of the
tapes could have busted or how hard it
should have actually been the lasso the
ping tape recorder
would you like to see her we you were
telling that story for an hour or did
you tell it for a few minutes and then
sit quietly for an hour and then out of
the blue asked would you like to see her
this article is about a boy who died in
an explosion playing with goofy clay
this article's an ACLU story about
people being followed by public and
private agents this article is also
about the boy who died in the explosion
due to Goofy clay back to the ACLU again
and this is about nuclear missiles or
something and they involved Stanley
Kubrick in it there's never a point in
the video when the camera moves like
this or is silent enough to isolate a
fire alarm in the distance without other
sounds interfering the savingly thing
about a war who said anything about a
warrant cliche actually an entire 60
seconds go by before singh shoots the
drills which means the puzzle making
mastermind killing genius can't estimate
time per sheet does jigsaw have a
constantly running fog machine in this
hallway
hey neat trap why is this the only place
in the building that has something like
that rigged I understand he probably had
a vest on or something maybe he's
supernatural I don't know but shouldn't
the gunshot that dropped into the ground
at least have torn some holes in his
robe
this was meant to receive calls that
make them yeah.but telephone law
requires all phones be able to dial
nine-one-one regardless of their
limitations the super smart serial
killer has every angle covered except
for decent audio and for that matter how
does Lawrence just assume that the
killer's microphone won't pick up
whispering maybe before you come up with
your super sneaky plan to pretend to
have him get poisoned by a cigarette you
could have made sure he wasn't the
world's worst actor I don't see how
jigsaw could have reached something here
that would create a successful electric
shock but doesn't appear to be anything
that would complete the circuit didn't
they try cutting through the rusty ass
pipes
how did Lawrence not hear this camera
clicking or see Adam at this distance
dial tone after the phone hangs up
cliche so when Lawrence told you about
the tall black cop who got his throat
cut you didn't make any connection there
were two cigarettes in the box and one
was thrown to Adam during the fake death
scene but now there are two cigarettes
on the floor and these guys are masters
at throwing photographs across the room
without them tailing off or flying out
of reach how did they get this picture
of Zeb peeking through the window when
he only did that this afternoon and only
tap could have taken it late he's
holding the wife and daughter captive in
the doctors own house so he kidnapped
them tied them up and then went and set
up all this computer and camera
equipment in the doctor's house I mean
even if this isn't the real jigsaw it's
the real jigsaw plan I'm very confused
about why he would choose to do this
what if the doctor doesn't pay his
Comcast bill or he has to dial up I mean
this is a super rich doctor who's too
cheap to buy his wife her own car it's
alright I've called the police
everything is okay
dude that is like almost the exact
perfect opposite of the truth also is it
fucking daylight right now was it not
pitch black nighttime just four minutes
ago when the killer and Danny Glover
were driving to the torture Shack
awesome twist now are we really supposed
to believe that he didn't need to
breathe for six hours or perhaps even
more ridiculous that he was breathing
the whole time but neither of the
prisoners ever noticed the slightest
movement an aging coughing cancer
patient manages to lie still for that
length of time can I just not buy this
for a second like the whole reason why
Lawrence is here is because he's
supposedly cheating on his wife however
Lawrence and Carla have not begun the
affair yet he says we see the encounter
in the hotel room where he tells her
what the rules are for calling
and like she made a mistake like a
rookie mistake she even refers to him as
dr. Gordon instead of you know his first
name these people have not started a
real affair yet
now maybe they stupidly flirted in front
of Zep or jigsaw or whoever at the
hospital they would have had to
specifically say in front of them
tonight for the very first time we make
love in a dirty hotel room sure hope no
one evil is eavesdropping right now but
even if they did something stupid like
that then jigsaw orbs effort whoever
would have still had to account for atom
how did they know about atom by atoms
account he's only been following
Lawrence for a few days they would have
had to figure out Adam existed figure
out that he was a type of guy who needed
to be taught a lesson too and lent
rigged the game on the fly to include it
also didn't he sort of miss the best
action by choosing to fake die facing
the kid instead of the doctor I mean he
likes to watch up victims right but he
didn't even see the guy who cut his own
foot off which for a psycho killer has
got to be like the best part each of
that chain is in the bathtub oh so the
key was never gonna be found anyway how
sporting of jigsaw how did he decide
that Adam was the biggest piece of in
the room and he practically drowns the
guy Adams death allows Lawrence to live
and jigsaw teases him at the end with
the key that he could never retrieve
photographers must be worse than Satan
you're selling peanut butter at a 15
hunger gang bet you want to know what
got these scars my father why I drink
her hey Dipper I have something for you
young man
Oh watch yourself it's Nicole oh oh the
claws coming at you oh you're scared of
the claw you know I stopped the line
you're a liar
you lie yeah a liar shut up
throw me the player No
you throw me your tank give me a wet
throw me the idol no time to argue
throw me the idol I feel you the week I
to go and get help I wish I knew how to
quit you
yes mr. Lowrey darlin
yeah too late
so now after all this time you've
decided to stop ignoring me